[Music]
first of all there's a whole question
about what what why is it that we in the
first place assume that we have
obligations towards robots so we think
that if something is intelligent then
that's that's their special source
that's that's why we have moral
obligations right and and why do we
think that because most of our moral
obligations the most important thing to
us is each other we're trying you know
so basically morality and ethics are the
way that we maintain human society
including by doing things like keeping
the environment okay you know making it
so we can live all right so one of the
ways we characterize ourselves is as
intelligent and so when we then see
something else and say oh it's more
intelligent well then maybe it needs
even more protection alright so that we
in AI we call that kind of reasoning
heuristic reasoning it's a good guess
it'll probably get you pretty far right
but it isn't necessarily true I mean
again how you define the term
intelligent will vary if you mean by
intelligent a moral agent you know
something that that's responsible for
its actions well then of course
intelligence implies moral agency when
will we know for sure that we need to
worry about robots well there's there's
all hotness questions there but
consciousness is another one of those
words the word I like to use is moral
patient it's a it's a tactical term that
the philosophers came up with and it
means exactly something that we are
obliged to take care of so now we can
have this conversation if you just mean
conscious means moral patient then then
it's no great assumption disabled then
if it's conscious then then we need to
be you know we need to take care of it
but it's a way more cool if you can say
does consciousness necessitate moral
patientsí right and then we can sit down
and say well it depends what you mean by
consciousness right people use
consciousness to mean a lot of different
things so one of the things that we did
last year which was pretty cool the
headlines because we were replicating
some psychology stuff about
implicit bias actually the best one is
something like scientists show that AI
is sexist and racist and it's our fault
which is that's pretty accurate because
it really is about picking things up
from our society anyway the point was so
here is an AI system that is so
human-like that it's picked up by our
prejudices and whatever and it's just
vectors it's not an ape it's not going
to take over the world it's not going to
do anything it's just a representations
like a photograph right and and so I the
the art we can't trust our intuitions
about these things we give things rights
because that's the best way we can find
to handle very complicated situations
and the things that we give rights are
basically people I mean some people
argue about animals but technically and
again this depends on who's technical
definition you use but technically
rights are usually things that come with
responsibilities and that you can defend
in a court of law so so normally we talk
about animal welfare and we talk about
human rights but the with with
artificial intelligence you can even
imagine itself knowing its rights and
defending itself in the court of law but
the question is why would we need to
protect the artificial intelligence with
rights why is that the best way to
protect it so with humans it's because
we're fragile it's because there's only
one of us and I actually think this is
horribly reductionist but I actually
think it's just the best way that we
found to be able to cooperate it's sort
of an acknowledgment of the fact that
we're all basically the same thing the
same stuff and we had to come up with
some kind of the technical term again is
equilibrium we had to come up with some
way to share the planet and we haven't
managed to do it completely fairly like
everybody gets the same amount of space
but actually we all want to be
recognized for our achievements so even
completely fair isn't completely fair if
that makes sense so and I don't mean to
be facetious there it really is true
that that you can't make all the things
you would like out of fairness
be true at once right that that's just
it's a fact about the world it's a fact
about the way we define fairness so
given how hard it is to be fair why
should we build AI that needs us
to be fair to it so what I'm trying to
do is just make the problem simpler and
focus us on the thing that we can't help
which is the human condition and I'm
recommending that if you if you if you
specify something if you say okay this
is when you really need rights in this
context okay once we establish that
don't build that okay yeah a lot of
people that this rubs them the wrong way
like it's because they fought you know
Blade Runner or or AI the movie or
something like this in a lot of these
movies we're not really talking about AI
we're not talking about something
designed from the ground up right we're
talking basically about clones and
clones they're a different situation if
you have something that's exactly like a
person however it was made then okay
then it's exactly like a person it needs
that kind of protection but even
biological clones even if you just want
to clone yourself at least in the
European Union that's illegal
right I I'm not sure about in America I
think it's illegal in America too but
people think it's unethical to create
human clones partly because they don't
want to burden someone with a knowledge
that they're supposed to be someone else
right that there was some other person
that chose them to be that person I
don't know if we'll be able to stick to
that but I would say that the that AI
clones fall into the same category if
you were really going to make something
and then say hey congratulations you're
me and you have to do what I say you
know I wouldn't want it myself to tell
me that what to do if that makes sense
up there were two of me right I think
we'd like to be able to both be equals
if they're you know and and so you don't
want to have an artifact is something
deliberately built in that you're going
to own if you have something that's sort
of a humanoid servant that you own then
the word for that is slave and so that I
was trying to establish that look we are
going to own anything we've
and so therefore it would be run to make
it a person because we've already
established that slavery of people is
wrong and bad and illegal right and so
it never occurred to me that people
would take that to mean that other
all--that's will be people that we just
treat really badly it's like no that's
exactly the opposite I already mentioned
that if somebody did manage to clone
people somehow which I don't believe
this is ever going to work but people do
talk about it they caught and they
people spend tens of millions of dollars
on it whole brain uploading so I don't
believe it's possible I don't think it's
actually computationally tractable but
but if it were to happen then yeah I
would be there saying yes this is a
person right but how can we stop that
the same way we stopped human cloning
which is just to say don't do that and
in particular with AI my point is it
shouldn't be a commercial product so if
somebody does this in their basement or
something well then we have a few
exceptions but it's I'm much more
concerned about people mass producing
such things
[Music]